رغم ان المانيا رابع واكبر مانح للدفاع
الاوكرانيه الا ان ترددها بشان النقل
دبابات ليوباغ اثنين لاكياف جعلها موضع شك
اوروبي لظهورها بموقع المرتبك وغير الراغب
في القياده فالمراوغه المطوله في مسائل
الامن الاوروبيه زعزعت ثقه عملائها
وشجعتهم على استكشاف خيارات اخرى للاجهزه
الدفاعيه وفي غياب قوه قياديه فرنسا
والمانيا تغيب اي خطوط انتاج دبابات ساخنه
اخرى في اوروبا ما فعل الخطط البديله
والتي تصب طبعا في كوريا الجنوبيه وفقا
لفرنسا حيث فازت شركه في كوريا الجنوبيه
بعقود اسلحه ضخمه مع بولندا العام الماضي
تضمنت صفقات لشراء 1000 دبابه قتال رئيسيه
وهي كي تو ومدافع ذات الدفع الصفقه
الكوريه وفرت بولندا الحصول على دبابات في
وقت اسرع وبسعر تنفسي طبعا كما ناسبت
رغباتها بنقل التكنولوجيا لتعزيز صناعه
الدفاع المحليه الخاصه بها الامر هنا لا
يقتصر على بولندا فقط فدت بابات القتال
الرئيسيه في تركيا مشتقه من ال تي طراز كي
تو وقد انخرطت دول مثل سلوفاكيا مع كوريا
الجنوبيه لمناقشه خيارات استبدال دبابات
تي 72 قديمه وكذلك النرويج وفنلندا
واستراليا
[موسيقى]